f1 2015 is a jekyll-and-hyde of a video
game in many ways it's the best Formula
One title code masters have ever
released a complete overhaul of the
series driving physics coupled with
wonderfully fun and challenging AI
competitors makes wrestling your car and
the games tracks more fun than ever but
f1 2015 also has an ugly side a shortage
of game modes numerous technical hiccups
and reliability issues that would make
even a Honda mechanic blush make it a
difficult game to recommend there's no
doubt that the on track action is far
better than last year's game but whether
or not you enjoy f1 2015 rest more and
if your favorite mode has been removed
and the frequency by which the game
crushes the desktop okay let's focus on
what works first the driving in this
year's game is the best that's ever been
and it's all down to the handling while
previous games in the series are more
forgiving when it came to traction
control this year's car is more
accurately reflect the high torque
nature of modern f1 this means you can
simply slam on the gas whenever you want
to go fast feathering the accelerator is
a must to ensure you make your way
around the track without spinning this
makes for a far more engaging Drive as
you battle for position and manage your
tyre wear while incoming rain showers
that reduce grip are more terrifying
than in previous games a word of caution
though for those who play with an Xbox
360 pod on their PC the triggers on the
360 controller are much shorter and lack
the Rumble feedback provided on the Xbox
one pad this means that you're required
to use incredible concentration and the
deafness of touches to ensure you don't
power out of a corner and spin your car
the game allows for unlimited flashbacks
and you can always turn traction control
up to full to mitigate these issues but
that kind of removes the most
challenging and enjoyable part of the
game let's just say it may be time to
buy an Xbox one pad for your PC or
better still a wheel and some pedals the
race engineer in f1 2015 is also a lot
more talkative providing a host of
genuinely useful information during
practice sessions through qualifying and
throughout the race itself during your
time in the car he keeps you up to speed
on your strategy on aspects of the track
you should focus your attention on even
notice if you're starting to struggle
with tire wear the engineer is not the
only one that feels more realistic
either the drivers in f1 2015 are well
capable of defending and overtaking
intelligently and of making rash
decisions that force you to take
avoiding action
this makes defending your position as
enjoyable
hunting down the car in front lap after
lap they are capable of making dumb
mistakes but all in all they feel more
human and provide more excitement than
in previous games in this series all
these aspects of driving wrestling the
car toying with race strategy and racing
wheel to wheel against your foes they
kept on 2050 in a game that often
delivers memorable racing moments
though quick race allows you to choose
any track and driver to take part in
everything from a full race weekend in
Melbourne to a short free lap spinner
and Yas Marina the bulk of the games
action takes place in championship
season here you take control of your
favorite f1 driver racing a full career
with practice and qualifying lengths to
your liking f1 2015 also comes with all
the drivers and tracks from last year's
season so you can go back in time from
the options menu if you want to drive
the Hockenheimring or pay your respects
to Jules Bianchi f1 2015 has also added
pro seasons mode which forces you into
full race weekends with realistic race
lengths in this mode you're also forced
to drive from the perspective of the
helmet with no on-screen display against
the toughest of AI competitors so it's
fair to say this isn't for the faint of
heart however the fact that a modified
version of the normal championship mode
receives its own place on the main menu
is telling of just how few ways there
are to play f1 2015 career mode is gone
meaning you can't create your own driver
like in previous games there is also no
co-op of any kind
you can't play locally with a friend in
split-screen anymore or take part in
co-op seasons like in previous games the
multiplayer menu has an option to play
with friends in individual races which
is probably just as well because in days
of trying to connect to any sort of
online Lobby I never once found a game
an entire graphics overhaul means f1
2015 looks better than ever but it's not
without its own issues
disappearing wheels and graphical
glitches take a sheen off an otherwise
great-looking Drive and while the PC at
work allowed me to play a few hours of
barely a hitch my home computer crashed
more than Pastor Maldonado on an opening
lap as wonderfully fun as the racing can
be in f1 2015 few things are more
frustrating than your PC crashing to
desktop after surviving 31 laps around
Marina Bay the game also has no safety
car not even the virtual safety car that
was added to the 2015 season so it's
pretty strange to see a four car pileup
happen behind you in Monaco only for the
race to continue as if nothing happened
and while in game crashes are more
spectacular than ever the car damage is
too inconsistent trauma to the back of
another car and your front wing has as
much chance of being totally unaffected
as it does realistically
breaking into pieces f1 2015 is an
incredibly frustrating game on PC
representing both a wonderful step
forward and a massive stumble serious
technical issues a dearth of game modes
and multiplayer which is functionally
broken on the PC Shara what is otherwise
a wonderful driving game if you can get
f1 2015 to run without crashing on your
machine and you're satisfied playing
championship mode this is a marvelously
fun driving game but just like in
Formula One racing no matter how good
your car feels around the track it cans
for nothing if you can't get it past the
checkered flag reliability is key in
racing right now f1 2015 on PC has far
too little of it
peace
you